the two of you had such horrible
beginnings as bad as it gets i'm talking
about your childhood does that bond you
in a sense perry i imagine your
addiction was steeped in pain the pain
of your childhood you know your mother
committed suicide when you were four
years old and billy's mother and father
divorced
and left billy essentially
he lived in how many different homes did
you live in like five different homes or
something yeah it was crazy time
crazy time i mean you're talking about
really bad [ __ ] you know as a child if
you go my mother is gone why did she
leave me that's the ultimate pain right
i mean yeah
yeah
i don't think it's uh i don't wanna say
better that's just the wrong word i
don't think it gets more difficult than
that especially your mother
because you're yeah you come from your
mother so if if you lose the root you're
well spring your source i mean where do
you go from there yeah
do you two ever take comfort in that
that you both had that same experience
where you were abandoned by your parents
do you both talk about that or is it too
heavy a thing you don't get into that i
don't ever have that i remember uh you
know it's just because out of respect i
don't want to bring up something that
might you know
hurt you real bad just off the top off
the top you know how did your mother
treat you or what happened to you unless
you're ready to talk about it
but you are right howard that
uh you know much like dave navarro
i find that people that have been you
know
really nailed in life
like i say that's the obstacle
but they seem to
if they if they can jump over the
obstacle
they've got a whole lot of news to to
tell people you know they become
messengers
that's what billy did
yeah i know about your past and i know
about your you know childhood i don't
talk about it but i do feel a kindred
spirit
yeah i mean my sense is when we're
together it's more or less like a
celebration you know what i mean
well yeah for me
my relationship with perry is very
personal because
you know i admired him before i knew him
and then he became a friend and and
knowing what he went through and knowing
what i went through and and and being
friends with eti as well and knowing our
partners talk about family like that's
such an accomplishment from where we
came from i'm not trying to project my
version on him but that's my sense of it
it's such an accomplishment that we have
stable relationships we have
warm homes we live in safe homes where
our partners really are the are the
true power in our lives
is such a beautiful thing so i look at
real admiration
uh with real admiration a perry that he
pulled his life together found a
wonderful partner has built a life
to be admired it's such a journey and to
and so you know literally for me the
first time i ever saw perry was wobbling
into a club
and i saw him play two nights later he
because we went back two nights later
when they played again
blew my mind one of the greatest fans
i've ever seen greatest live right i
mean it doesn't get any better thank you
so seeing that and that's great too
thank you but to see that and then
break bread together and know each
other's families
and still be connected and to have such
warmth that that's the con that's what
he's saying that's the accomplishment
but that's also something that only he
and i could understand in a particular
way yeah you know